тут два-два можливих розвідки сценаріїв
перший і він дуже реалістичний це те що
нарешті знайшлася можливість помститися
пригожину за те що робили вогнери і як
вони ставили під питання авторитет
Путіна
ця відповідь десь мусила бути але з
іншого боку теж може бути як варіант Тут
зараз подумалося що це Таким чином
пригожин міг сам себе ліквідувати в
мається на увазі в інформаційному часу
просторі і потім собі спокійно жити на
якихось островах і аматингу слухай тут
знаєш у чому проблема що не просто так
летів летів і впав А те що його збило
російське ПВО Що скажу земля йому
бетоном хвилинку часу мене хвилю
є Чому ти зараз ти зараз от у цю хвилину
ти політичний аналітик земля бетоном
не пройде У мене не пройде Значить
дивись
наприклад загибель пригожина і Україна
давай забудемо Росію ну збили і збили
Так Значить що ми маємо Мабуть буде
після цього повна деструкція
чвк Вагнера як компаній тому що як
лідера нема то значить вони ну будуть
брати їх наприклад Міністерство оборони
Росії і так далі Який висновок я роблю
приємний для нас
що не буде вже такого гол телого знаєш
як то кажуть отакого отакого от який в
Росії був дуже популярний
і можливо у нього були зазіхання значно
більші аніж розумієш Мені здається що з
політичного боку це дуже важлива для нас
історія А ну насправді
розумієш тут жива присутність була би
цікавішою тому що поки два табори
безжерлися між собою хто більше
можливості для влади має тим більше
можливостей для України в момент їхніх
внутрішніх сварок визволяти своїй
території але з тим що я зараз працюю з
тими підрозділами з якими ми зараз так
само і опікуються з ким комунікую то
зараз не
немає так багато інформації про вагнерів
на тих позиціях йдеться про те що на
багатьох позиціях є професійна
Московська армія
професійний Спецназ не зеки не якісь там
ряжені генерали навіть не оці от
вагнерівці які мають свою власну
структури а йдеться в саме про вишулену
Московську армію з якою дуже непросто
боротися і яку дуже не треба до
оцінювати дуже треба
скажемо не можна недооцінювати як таку
тому
я більше схильна думати насправді що це
нарешті поквиталися з тим хто ставив під
сумнів авторитет Путіна але так але
варто власне ПВО
зараз буде купа всяких пояснень Зараз
воно все обросте відповідно потрібною
для Путіна інформаційної кампанії але
давайте подивимося що просто майже усіх
хто заважали тому чи іншому режиму в
Московському царстві Федерації
красиво ліквідовували ну це це звична
практика так знаєш відверто отак
відверто кажучи думали що це е 16
наприклад
летить на мосту да Слухай у нас
під'єднується Давай заблудилися сьогодні
А оті що заблудилися да